you're my best friend I love you Katie
white
I love you so much I love you
so
Katie
will you marry me absolutely
Bachelor Zach shallcross engaged to
Katie bigger are you happy
I'll tell you this I'm very happy but
ahead of Zach's happy ending he had to
deal with the messy aftermath of his
fantasy suite dates specifically
breaking his no sex rule I'm really hurt
I feel like I've committed some sort of
crime last week felt like a big step
back the finale kicks off with Ariel who
Zach sent home at the previous Rose
ceremony she reveals during the live
after show she didn't know he was
intimate with Gabby until it aired last
week I was really disappointed in the
way the whole week was handled I was
disappointed in the way that I was left
completely not knowing anything from
Zach when Ariel confronts Zach she
doesn't hold back by putting sex off the
table you made the entire week about sex
and it didn't need to be like that you
took away my agency and you took away my
ability to even have a conversation and
if you had waited you would have found
out that I was on the same page as you
how you're feeling throughout the whole
journey even though it's tough you have
to be vulnerable then there's Gabby who
accepted one of Zach's final two roses
she admits she doesn't feel great about
the decision to suspend the night
I'm feeling very guilty because I feel
like I was like an accessory in a crime
but Zach makes it clear he doesn't
regret anything that was huge for us
I wouldn't take anything back like
hearing it
that you felt pain and that you caused
this like you opened my eyes and
anything like you were like someone I in
my heart like I
like it's love
[Music]
I want you to know that feelings are at
stake and you know the women are doing
the same and you're just laying your
heart out on the line but when Katie has
alone time with Zach she tells him how
she really feels about the Gabby
situation I've gone to know Gabby and
she's an unreal girl and
obviously don't need to tell you that
this whole thing has been like very
tough on me and
I think like last week we kind of hit a
little bit of a hurdle at the time it
felt like a big step back he honestly
just wants to find his wife and like he
said he wants to find his best friend
and that's what I want to find as well
after after the two ladies meet Zach's
parents and go on one more date it was
time for the final Rose ceremony I have
got feelings
and I think if it were me I'd know it
was me
as much as I've been falling in love
with you
I don't want to hear it
okay
I'm sorry and that leaves
exactly Lane I am so in love with you
and I can't I just like you are my world
you're the only one I want in my life oh
my God I want to spend life with you
we're engaged
yeah Zach put a ring on it and the
lovebirds couldn't be happier it's you
it's
it's always been you and I want to spend
the rest of my life with this woman
[Music]